a c e d b k no this isn't some random
out of order alphabet these are vitamins
and just like letters billed words
they're the building blocks that keep
the body running vitamins are organic
compounds we need to ingest in small
amounts to keep functioning they're the
body's builders defenders and
maintenance workers helping it to build
muscle and bone make use of nutrients
capture and use energy and heal wounds
if you need convincing about vitamin
value just consider the plight of olden
days sailors who had no access to
vitamin rich fresh produce
they got scurvy but vitamin C abundant
in fruits and vegetables was the simple
antidote to this disease while bacteria
fungi and plants produce their own
vitamins our bodies can't so we have to
get them from other sources so how does
the body get vitamins from out there
into here that's dependent on the form
these compounds take vitamins come in
two types lipid soluble and water
soluble and the difference between them
determines how the body transports and
stores vitamins and gets rid of the
excess the water-soluble ZAR vitamin C
and B complex vitamins that are made up
of eight different types that each do
something unique these are dissolved in
the watery parts of fruits vegetables
and grains meaning their passage through
the body is relatively straightforward
once inside the system these foods are
digested and the vitamins within them
are taken up directly by the bloodstream
because blood plasma is water-based
water-soluble vitamin C and B have their
transport cut out for them and can move
around freely within the body for lipid
soluble vitamins dissolved in fat and
found in foods like dairy butter and
oils this trip into the blood is a
little more adventurous these vitamins
make it through the stomach and the
intestine where an acidic substance
called bile flows in from the liver
breaking up the fat and preparing it for
absorption through the intestinal wall
because fat soluble vitamins can't make
use of the Bloods watery nature they
need something else to move them around
and that comes from protein
that attached to the vitamins and act
like couriers transporting fat-soluble
into the blood and around the body so
this difference between water or fat
soluble vitamins determines how they get
into the blood but also how they're
stored or ejected from the body the
system's ability to circulate
water-soluble vitamins in the
bloodstream so easily means that most of
them can be passed out equally easily
via the kidneys because of that most
water-soluble vitamins need to be
replenished on a daily basis through the
food we eat
but fat soluble vitamins have staying
power because they can be packed into
the liver and in fat cells the body
treats these parts like a pantry storing
the vitamins there and rationing them
out when needed meaning we shouldn't
overload on this type of vitamin because
the body is generally well stocked once
we've figured the logistics of transport
and storage the vitamins are left to do
the work they came here to do in the
first place some like many of the B
complex vitamins make up coenzymes whose
job it is to help enzymes release the
energy from food other B vitamins then
help the body to use that energy from
vitamin C you get the ability to fight
infection and make collagen a kind of
tissue that forms bones and teeth and
heals wounds vitamin A helps make white
blood cells key in the body's defense
helps shape bones and improves vision by
keeping the cells of the eye in check
vitamin D gathers calcium and phosphorus
so we can make bones and vitamin E works
as an antioxidant getting rid of
elements in the body that can damage
cells finally from vitamin K we score
the ability to clot blood since it helps
make the proteins that do this job
without this vitamin variety humans face
deficiencies that cause a range of
problems like fatigue nerve damage heart
disorders or diseases like rickets and
scurvy on the other hand too much of any
vitamin can cause toxicity in the body
so there goes the myth that loading
yourself with supplements is a great
idea in reality it's all about getting
the balance right and hitting that
vitamin jackpot
you